I got yellow to show recently this guy
goes hey buddy that's a trigger word I
was like whoa I think it's pronounced
trigger
easy there big fella
upset or offended that's cool I'm not
one of those guys you're allowed to be
offended that's totally cool but if you
are just shut up
not a hero he's just ruining a show just
be offended just let it flow through you
just feel it right yeah don't share we
don't care just feel yeah we all have
thoughts I might want to sleep with your
girlfriend I just hold it in I don't say
it yeah yeah
yeah I just feel it or so obsessed with
words now kind of shows how good we have
we've got to focus on Words you know
like in the 70s it was all about actions
like if you want to show your Brave in
the 70s you had to jump over 12 buses on
a motorcycle now I see a guy make an
off-color joke at the office I'm like
that guy's [ __ ] Fearless holy [ __ ]
wow
yeah I don't know people take things so
seriously I guess they gotta show you
their personality by yelling at you
about stuff that bothers them I don't
know like I don't mean any of this stuff
I'm just saying words in a certain order
to elicit laughter people like try to
figure me out do my ACT it's all jokes I
told an abortion joke recently and a
woman approached me she was like hey
that's very insensitive I've had an
abortion you shouldn't tell jokes like
that I was like whoa hey sorry I just
told a joke I think what you did was
much worse
thank you
but you know
either way I'll see at home later honey
and again all jokes I love abortions I
paid for two last week I'm a fan right
you remember come on
it's all jokes a friend of mine she
works at Planned Parenthood she loves
that joke and I was like I might have to
get rid of it people don't like it she's
like no no you got to keep it I was like
I might get rid of she's like no no you
got to keep but I was like
yeah
I was like don't tell me dude with my
body of work she's like every joke's a
miracle
foreign
but I don't want to upset anybody you
know
oh geez
I don't want to upset that's not my
intention you know I'm upsetting people
on accident now I was at a Starbucks
recently this guy handed my coffee I
went hey thanks Chief this guy goes ooh
don't say Chief it's offensive to Native
Americans
I was like how is that offensive he goes
whoa don't say how
do we get here
weird times weird times
taking words away you know I get it you
know words hurt people I get it you know
but here's the thing we're kind of like
a weird word prohibition can't say this
can't say that that's why I feel like
every now and then we should all go to a
politically incorrect Speak Easy this is
where we can all go to say horrible
stuff and nobody cares you got no Hate
in Your Heart you don't want to hurt
anybody but if you can't say it there
give us a place you can right you go
down some creaky stairs you bang on a
big steel door the guy's like what's the
password [ __ ] get it
again huh because offensive words
they're like alcohol sure you can abuse
it sure you can hurt people if you do
responsibly it's a good time yeah
just don't do it at work don't do around
kids but go home close the door take the
edge off ah [ __ ]
right I don't say little people that's
like drinking no duels
but of course I get it I just you know
find it funny I get it but here's the
problem we forget that no one's
politically correct up here we're all
animals we're all trying to we're all
seeing the same thing we're all thinking
the same thing no one's PC in their
brain that's just a filter problem when
he talks you seem nice like no one sees
a hot girl bend over and thinks look at
that independent woman like to treat her
equally
ah we're sick man and women we're gross
but look where it's all gotten us then I
feel like the whole country's pent up
feels everybody's angry right now we got
white supremacists protests hate groups
it's weird you're allowed to be hateful
in America as long as you're not
specific isn't that weird and if you're
like I hate Mexican people everybody's
like oh my God what a bigot Prejudice
but if you're like I hate people
everybody's like [ __ ] right
isn't that worse people are angry now
man I have one of those uh White lives
matter rallies go by my house the other
day I freaked out then I realized oh
it's just a half marathon
foreign
I don't know just be a good person what
about that just be nice to people you
know yeah like uh a lot of it doesn't
add up I can't keep track of all the
rules like transgender what do you think
that's how I feel I don't give a [ __ ]
you want to go for a man a woman go nuts
well go labia
beef look it's weird to hate someone
because they're trans right but it's
also weird to love someone because
they're trans shouldn't you like them
based on who they are as a person
content of the character people are so
phony I love Caitlyn Jenner why she
sucks
she's against gay marriage ran over a
person what's the good part
then they go well they have hard lives
all right well so do midgets
why don't you talk about how much you
like them where's that hashtag I don't
see any tweets about midgets who's got a
heart on a minute hard to get around
hard to drive hard to get work no love
and look I'm not anti-trans but I am
pro-mage
just don't get why we help one group but
not another it's just kind of trendy and
people say well Trends aren't allowed
everywhere well you've been a roller
coaster
[Music]
at least trans me accommodate with the
bathrooms midgets you ever see how tall
a toilet is what imagine having a jump
to take a dump
weird
no help no support
and you know what's great about midgets
I got a couple [ __ ] friends they're
good eggs
you never see a [ __ ] complaining
never every other group complains never
a [ __ ] never see it on the news sit on
a desk legs dang a little fish never
every other group complains I see women
on news we have a glass ceiling midgets
like you're worried about the ceiling
holy [ __ ]
I'm trying to [ __ ] with this counter
baby
foreign
see I guess I'm too open-minded because
I support all transition not just sexual
why do we stop at sexual I support
transition to personality transition of
uh opinion right like Kevin Hart Kevin
Hart got in trouble with some offensive
tweets from years ago I'm not the same
guy I was from years ago I've
transitioned I used to have sex with 16
year olds
when I was 16.
now I don't I'm Different well years ago
he said some offensive stuff well years
ago she won the men's relay people
change
why do you support that and not that huh
it just tells me if I ever get into
trouble now I'm just going to get a sex
change because you got to kiss my ass
hey Mark we heard that interview from 10
years ago that was Mark I'm Margaret
I don't know I support Kevin Hart also
because he's a [ __ ]
oh there we go